josh brolin this summer you must you're
gonna be causing like nerdgasm yes in
people because like because the poor
nerds won't know they won't understand
cuz you're right they're gassing yes
they'll be happy they're gasping I like
how confused they just be in Avengers
infinity war but you're also in a
Deadpool to like home like what's the
timeline what's happening I don't
understand it at 3 weeks apart coming
out three weeks apart and Avengers did
well quite well and we'll break all
those records you know your films
they're your intro but you haven't done
these kind of big blockbusters with CGI
and explosions of things you like you
nice when you do milk or No Country for
Old Men it doesn't matter because you
started so therefore you can get away
with anything you want shocking only
because I've met one other person who
hasn't seen or at least admitted
[Applause]
a lot of people are lying cuz I was like
have no idea no never seen I've never
seen this show they don't know who
anybody is should see The Goonies you
should have some access to outside
information yet just go now you're about
Deadpool too now the film's next Tuesday
and it seems like you're quite enjoying
the press tour you're having a nice time
yeah you know you if you're gonna jump
in the water may as well swim yeah
review in Rome enjoying yeah Josh
falling deeper and deeper there your
honeymoon picture it really is like it's
sort of like CGI in the background like
we didn't we weren't actually outside we
like this more I mean I told him this
this morning I wrote a text to him last
night and I said you know I've really
had a good time like these things can
not be so fun and then sometimes they
can be fun in my love letter it was a
love that I felt really good about not
only how it was written but the heart
behind it and then this morning I went
down to the gym and the first person I
see the only person I see in the gym is
him and you want to do nothing but avoid
the pitch you wrote the tech guy barely
made eye contact you had feelings for
Ron before you met Ryan are you telling
me this or is this something you said no
I have said it I saw the proposal and I
have no shame now saying that even
though I saw it alone all three times
was a fan Wow
I am a fan I just cannot wrap my head
around you and studying and watching
their proposal yeah be watching and just
being like [ __ ] this guy
that when I saw green lantern
[Applause]
[Music]
you